aquí tenemos varios periodos de tiempo
en minutos y lo que queremos hacer es
transformarlos a su equivalente en
segundos el primer intervalo es
inmediato un minuto es igual a 60
segundos esto es por definición un
segundo es una sexagésima parte de un
minuto y a cuánto equivale en cinco
minutos podemos visualizar esto de la
siguiente manera si este es un minuto
sabemos que equivale a 60 segundos
entonces vamos a copiar este intervalo
cinco veces aquí tenemos dos minutos
sacamos otra copia hacemos otra copia
aquí tenemos tres minutos otro minuto
más cuatro minutos y un último minuto
más cinco minutos aquí tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro cinco minutos es decir cinco
por sesenta y cinco por 60 son 300
segundos vamos a ponerlo aquí 5 por 60
es igual a 300 segundos
ahora para calcular cuántos segundos en
diez minutos hacemos lo mismo 10 minutos
son
por 60 segundos que son 600 segundos 60
minutos son 60 x 60 60 segundos que hay
en cada minuto por 60 minutos
estos son 3600 segundos habiendo hecho
esto vayamos un poco más lejos
convirtamos ahora de horas
a minutos de horas a minutos 10 segundos
y para empezar digamos que tenemos vamos
a hacer algo que sea inmediato empecemos
con una hora una hora por definición son
60 minutos una hora son 60 minutos y 60
minutos ya lo calculamos acá abajo son
60 x 60 3600 segundos
así es que una hora equivale a 3600
segundos
bien calculemos ahora a cuánto equivale
en dos horas si tenemos que hay 60
minutos en cada hora en dos horas va a
haber dos por 60 minutos y esto es igual
a 2 por 60 120 minutos y eso cuántos
segundos son bueno hay dos maneras de
hacer esto podemos pensar que hay que
multiplicar 120 por 60
dado que sabemos que cada minuto tiene
60 segundos o si ya sabemos que una hora
son 3 mil 600 segundos múltiple
entonces por 2 esto sería 2 por 3600 que
es igual a 7200 segundos
finalmente vamos a convertir 10 horas 10
horas en minutos ya sabemos que es 10
por 60 minutos que hay en cada hora y
estos son 600 minutos y esto en segundos
es 10 por 3600 que son el número de
segundos que hay en cada hora
si tenemos 10 horas y hay 3600 segundos
en cada hora esto nos da igual a 3600
por 10 agregamos simplemente un cero
para obtener 36.000 segundos 10 horas
equivalen a 36.000 segundos